und zurück live hier Plenum und es geht
los mit der aktuellen Stunde die
altkanzlerin Angela Merkel wurde ja am
vergangenen Montagabend mit dem höchsten
deutschen Verdienstorden ausgezeichnet
Bundespräsident Frank Walter Steinmeier
hat ihr das Großkreuz des
Verdienstordens der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland in besonderer Ausführung
verliehen das fanden nicht alle
angemessen deswegen hat die AFD unter
anderem hier eine Aktuelle Stunde
beantragt erster Redner jetzt Stefan
Brandner
zuständig war bei geringster
Energieversorgungssicherheit und die
Industriealisierung unseres Landes
verursacht hat was geschieht mit einer
Frau deren Politik eine marode
Infrastruktur gesperrte und verkommene
Straßen Autobahnen und Brücken eine
Deutsche Bahn die wenn die Züge
überhaupt fahren Männer Zufall arbeitet
eine Bundeswehr die am Ende ist und die
einen eklatanten Fachkräftemangel durch
eine wahnsinnige Bildungspolitik die
viele wahnsinnige hervorgebracht hat man
denke an Klima Klimakrise
und Trans Geschlechter verursacht hat
das passt übrigens das Satzende zum Satz
Anfang was geschieht also mit jemandem
die und deren Politik für Versagen
durchgängiges Versagen überall für
galoppieren die Inflation für
zigtausende Corona im Opfer versteht und
die wieder die kaum zu wieder
gutmachenden Schaden für Deutschland
angerichtet hat so das waren jetzt viele
fragen meine Damen und Herren ich löse
auf eine solche Frau wird in Deutschland
nicht etwas verurteilt und eingesperrt
sondern sie erhält den höchstmöglichen
Ort und das von einem Scherz Steinmeier
der viele Jahre Deutschland verneinend
und verachtende Politik mit Frau Merkel
gemacht hat und Frau Merkel dieses Amt
verdammt das ist so durchschaubar das
ist schäbig einheitlich die andere das
ist ein altparteienstaat den ich mir ein
dunkelsten Träumen nicht hätte
vorstellen können merkel muss weg
das war gut und richtig kam aber wie wir
alle wissen sehr spät und ich wünschte
mir aber als ehrlich gesagt eine Stunde
Merkel zurück dass sie da auf diesem
Stuhl Platz nehmen könnte und sich
anhören müsste was die Nachwelt über sie
und ihr Treiben denkt nämlich gar nichts
mehr es ist auch schon in der CDU
angekommen Herr Lindemann Euch hat sich
schon öffentlich Herr März Hummelt und
Grenze noch so ein bisschen rum aber den
einen oder anderen den man ja von ihnen
bei parlamentarischen sieht im Fahrstuhl
trifft oder auch bei Auslandsreisen
spricht David klar sie wollen mit Merkel
und ihrer Politik und deren Politik
nichts mehr zu tun haben und das ist
auch gut so das ist auch gut so gleich
wo kommt die Einsicht bei ihnen zu spät
sie haben jahrelang am Rockzipfel von
Merkel gegangen ganz devot ihre eigenen
Küsschen Willen das war schädlich und
was schäbig ist ist dass sie die Politik
die sie noch bis vor einem Jahr
gnadenlos und konkurrenzlos und
widerspruchslos umgesetzt haben
plötzlich verneinen Stichwort sich
verlangen die knallharte asylinder sie
wollen plötzlich den Ausstieg aus
Ausstieg der Kernenergie tun so als
hätten sie gar nichts damit zu tun heute
morgen haben wir an diesem Rednerpult
gesprochen über teilweise partielle
Amnesie des Bundeskanzlers bei ihnen ist
eine pauschale Amnesie der Politik der
letzten Jahre vorhanden liebe Kollegen
von der CDU CSU stellen wir uns kurz vor
wo wir
wären wir hätten Milliarden Euro in
Deutschland investiert werden die besten
Schulen die besten Hochschulen die
besten Straßen die besten
Bahnverbindungen die besten
Energiepreise bei höchster
Versorgungssicherheit werden kaum
Inflation wir wären ja aus dem Euro
ausgetreten wir hätten gute ausgebildete
Fachkräfte Ärzte Akademiker es wären
Rentner in Deutschland die leben könnten
nach einem aufopferungsvollen leben
wollen ihrer Rente die könnten ihn
Sicherheit leben wir hätten kurz und
knapp blühende Landschaften in
Deutschland warum haben die nicht weil
sie Frau Merkel gestutzt haben Frau
Merkel hat das Bundesverdienstkreuz als
Großkreuz in besonderer Ausführung
verlieren bekommen und das ist verliehen
bekommen hat das gibt uns Mut wenn eine
Laie eine leise kann man zurückfordern
nach Paragraph 64 Absatz 3 BGB und das
wird die Alternative für Deutschland tun
sobald wir Einfluss haben wir sagen wir
werden Staatsanwälte dabei unterstützen
die Ermittlungen vor Merkel einzuladen
wir sagen Frau Merkel ist viel mehr an
einem Haftbefehl als an einer
Ordensverleihung dafür stehen wir als
Alternative für Deutschland hier und
unseren WLAN gegenüber gerade vielen
Dank
Stefan Brandner war das für die
afd-fraktion die hier diese aktuelle
Stunde beantragt hat zur
Ordensverleihung an
altkanzlerin Angela Merkel jetzt gehen
wir in die aktuelle Stunde mit dem
nächsten Redner helgolind für die SPD
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wenn man vor ihrer reden Herr
Brandner Angela Merkel nicht schon
schätzte nach ihrer Rede liebt man sie
man hat gar keine Alternative
eine Ahnung von Gemeinsinn entwaffener
Humor und auch die Fähigkeit zur
Selbstkritik das sind Qualitäten die
Angela Merkel hatte und hat und sie sind
genau das worüber die AFD noch nie
verfügt hat oder jemals verfügen wird
insofern ist es ja auch bezeichnen dass
sie diese aktuelle Stunde heute
beantragt haben es sagt sehr viel über
sie und im genauen Titel steht ja auch
dass man das Großkreuz des
Verdienstordens nicht entwerten solle
das ist natürlich das Maximum der
Selbstironie wenn sie von entwartung
sprechen wo sie der Inbegriff der
Entwertung aller Werte der Abwertung von
allem und der maximalen wertelosigkeit
sind danke für dieses Eigentor dass sie
geschossen haben
Angela Merkel war jemand wenn ich jetzt
biografisch spreche bei denen ich mich
auch gewöhnt hatte viele Jahre noch
lange bevor ich im Bundestag war mich
manchmal chemisch einzulassen oder zu
stöhnen ob ihrer Sprödheit der reden
oder ihrer Gelassenheit oder ihrer
Freude am zu warten oder fehlen dazu
Spitzen das ist auch die Kritik die man
jetzt teilweise in der Presse und erst
recht aber in ganz andere Form in ihren
Hasstiraden hören
was diejenigen die sich da aber
einlassen und das reicht von
Engstirnigkeit und Kleinkariertheit bis
zu blanken Hass bei Ihnen bei ihm liegt
ja eine regelrechte merkelmani vor was
ein Kompliment für die altkanzlerin ist
ja was man bei all dem übersieht ist
dass die die gerne kritisieren oft nicht
das zustande gebracht haben nämlich
Ausstieg aus dem Ausstieg Entscheidung
zu korrigieren oder ich erwähne die
Osterpause in der Pandemie oder auch
Kurskorrekturen in der Euro-Krise die
Fähigkeit sich zu distanzieren und
eigene Entscheidungen in Frage zu
stellen das zeichnet viele
Spitzenpolitiker auch in diesem Land
historisch nicht aus diese Kanzlerin war
aber dazu in der Lage und das muss man
denke ich würde
zudem wird ja auch häufig jetzt die
Frage der Außenpolitik und von
Versäumnissen der Sicherheitspolitik und
Verteidigungspolitik genannt und ich
finde es auch richtig dass das benannt
werden muss und kann denn wenn jemand
für seine Verdienste geehrt wird ist das
ja keine Heiligsprechung keine
allgeographie gleichzeitig aber finde
ich sehr merkwürdig und sehr
eigentümlich wenn dann ihnen Bezug auf
Russland gerade diejenigen die selbst
damals zum Teil zugestimmt haben oder
die ist auch nicht anders sagen
besonders laut kritisieren und ich finde
es vorbildlich wie gerade Lars klingen
weil es gemacht hat nämlich ein
deutliches Bekenntnis zur Zeitenwende
aber auch schonungslose Selbstkritik in
Bezug auf die Sozialdemokratie ohne jede
Selbstgerechtigkeit und ohne trimonal
und ohne Anklage sie hat es falsch
gemacht so macht man es und dieser Lars
kriegen weil war auch in der Lage in der
Talkshow Maischberger
Angela Merkel zu gratulieren wozu nach
Zick versuchen Friedrich Merz nicht im
Stange war leider ich bedauere das denn
ich finde angela Merkel ist jemand auf
den auch die CDU stolz sein kann und
ganz bemerkenswert ist es doch wenn man
mal den Blick raus wird und ich sage das
bewusster Sozialdemokrat 2019 wurde
Angela Merkel geehrt mit dem Ehrendoktor
Titel in Hauert vor ihr sprach jemand
algerische Herkunft jemand
dominikanischer Herkunft und jemand
indischer Herkunft und all diejenigen
würdigten insbesondere ihre
Migrationspolitik und die Entscheidung
2015 aus der Sicht der AFD natürlich
sind Menschen die Abschlüsse in Harvard
machen und ihre Reden wie der indische
Student auf Lateinisch halten Idioten
ich könnte mir auch vorstellen dass die
Idiot bei der AFD liegt und dass die
Arbeit absolvieren recht gehabt haben
und das stört mich und ärgert mich auch
übrigens in der
Bemerkung von den Linnemann der von
eklatanten Fehlern in der
flüchtlingskrise sprach
außerhalb
doch mit nicht nur
frische geflüchtete die hergekommen sind
sondern Menschen mit unterschiedlicher
Migrationsgeschichte alle haben höchsten
Respekt vor dieser Entscheidung denn das
ist eine Entscheidung gewesen bei allen
Defiziten die identitätsstiftend war
Mauern zu nein merkeln alles nur
Belastung zu sehen das ist nicht
identitätsstiften und vor allem finden
diese Personen und das ist das letzte
was ich sagen würde eines bemerkenswert
an dieser Kanzlerin nämlich dass sie
nicht auffield durch toxische
Männlichkeit aller Brandner dass sie
bescheiden war demütig und
zurückgenommen und dass den Weg zeigte
das Politik möglich ist ohne
Polarisierung ohne Machtgehabe denn
viele Menschen anderen Ländern der Welt
erleben nur Politiker die das Gegenteil
machen die dicke Hose präsentieren die
den Brandner geben und die das Gegenteil
von Kompromiss Verständnis und Empathie
verkörpern deshalb herzlichen
Glückwunsch Angela Merkel
sagt der Sozialdemokrat Helge Lindt hier
im Deutschen Bundestag ja hat Angela
Merkel diese höchste deutsche
Auszeichnung verdient dazu gab es sehr
viele Wortmeldungen in den letzten Tagen
von der AFD haben wir die Kritik schon
gehört
lob kam von den parteiche von SPD und
Grünen beispielsweise und aus ihrer
eigenen Partei der CDU auch ihr gewinnt
hat es eben schon angesprochen hat sich
beispielsweise sehr stellvertretende
CDU-Vorsitzende Carsten Linnemann
durchaus kritisch geäußert das sei
offenkundig das merke große Verdienste
hätte auch gerade internationale aber
sie haben auch Fehler gemacht sogar
eklatante hören wir mal was die CDU
CSU-Fraktion heute hier im Bundestag
sagt Thorsten freie Parlament ischer
Geschäftsführer weit oben für den Herrn
aber
sehr verehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das Großkreuz in besonderer Ausfertigung
des Verdienstordens der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland hat es in der Geschichte
unseres Landes bislang erst dreimal
gegeben und wir sind sehr stolz darauf
dass es drei ehemalige Bundeskanzler aus
unseren Reihen wahren wir sind auch
stolz darauf dass es jetzt die erste
Frau die erste ostdeutsche ist die mit
dieser
herausgehobenen Auszeichnung zu Recht
geehrt wird und meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wenn man eine Person eine Politikerin
würdigen möchte dann muss man das
natürlich in den historischen Kontext
stellen und jetzt muss man sich das
einmal vor Augen führen unter welchen
schwierigen herausfordernden
Rahmenbedingungen die Kanzlerschaft von
Angela Merkel stattgefunden hat im Jahr
1990 haben viele Menschen geglaubt dass
es ein Ende der Geschichte gäbe Francis
Fukuyama hat es so formuliert und wir
haben gerade in der Kanzlerschaft von
Angela Merkel gesehen dass mit dem Fall
des Eisernen Vorhangs der Siegeszug der
liberalen Demokratie eben nicht
zwangsläufig verbunden war sondern ganz
im Gegenteil und wir haben nicht nur
herausfordernde internationale
Beziehungen erlebt in dieser
Kanzlerschaft sondern auch
innerstaatliche Herausforderungen die
ihresgleichen gesucht haben das hat
begonnen in ihrer Kanzlerschaft mit
einer weltweiten Wirtschaftskrise die
ein gutes Stück weit auch die
Strukturprobleme des Finanzsystems
offengelegt haben eine Wirtschaftskrise
die sich entwickelt hat zu einer Finanz-
und Währungskrise wo nicht klar war
inwieweit unsere gemeinsame europäische
Währung dem standhalten kann eine
migrationskrise eine Pandemie wie wir
sie die letzten 100 Jahre nicht erlebt
haben und es war Angela Merkel die unser
Land mit kluger Hand durch diese
schwierigen Zeiten geführt haben hat und
dafür gesorgt hat dass unser Land über
hohe Anerkennung und Reputation in der
Welt verfügt hat
und wenn sie sich mal
anschauen was das im Einzelnen für die
Menschen bedeutet hat dann kann man das
an vielen einzelnen Punkten festmachen
ich finde ganz besonders eindrucksvoll
in den Titelgeschichten des britischen
economes
2005 sick man of Europe
also in fünf Jahren vom kranken Mann
Europas zur Zugmaschine Europas das ist
die Kanzlerschaft von Angela Merkel und
CDU CSU geführten Bundesregierungen
gewesen und meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren was heißt das für die
Menschen mehr als die Halbierung der
Arbeitslosigkeit von 11,7 auf 5,7
Prozent in diesen 16 Jahren ein
Höchststand an
sozialversicherungspflichtigen
Beschäftigungsverhältnissen die
Schuldenbremse über 20 Jahre hatten wir
in Deutschland jedes Jahr mehr Geld
ausgegeben als wir eingenommen haben in
den letzten sieben Jahren vor Ausbruch
der Pandemie keine neuen Schulden
Rückführung der Verschuldung in
Deutschland von 81 Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts auf 58 Prozent
zeigen Sie mir ein anderes G7 oder
g20-land dass das geschafft hat und auch
die Investitionen in die Zukunft die
Etat für Bildung für Forschung für
Wissenschaft haben sich verdreifacht in
dieser Zeit es waren herausragende
Erfolge die letztlich auch dazu geführt
haben dass wir einen unglaublichen
Wohlstandszuwachs in diesen 16 Jahren
erlebt haben von denen die Menschen in
unserem Land profitiert haben und gerade
weil es so ist lieber Herr Lindt ich
finde es schön dass Sie anerkennende
Worte in ihrer Rede gefunden haben ich
fand es auch richtig wie
Sozialdemokraten auf diese herausragende
Ehrung reagiert haben umso
unverständlicher ist es dass sie und
andere Redner ihre Fraktion hier im
Deutschen Bundestag seit 18-20 Monaten
alles dafür tun um mit den gemeinsamen
Erfolgen der Vergangenheit nichts mehr
zu tun haben zu müssen
und vor diesem Hintergrund ist doch
vollkommen klar
diese Erfolge kann man nicht ernsthaft
bestreiten und sie anzuerkennen bedeutet
im Übrigen in der Demokratie nicht dass
man einen
unfehlbarkeitsorten verleihen würde
natürlich nicht in der Politik zu malen
der Demokratie kann man immer darüber
streiten ob man diese Lösung wählt ob
man eine andere Lösung wählt das tun wir
ja hier im Parlament und deswegen muss
man ganz klar sagen Politiker werden
natürlich in aller erster Linie in
demokratischen Wahlen gemessen und
Angela Merkel hat für ihre Politik
viermal hintereinander bei
Bundestagswahlen herausragende
Mehrheiten erzielt die Wahrheit blickt
in der Urne und deswegen ist es glaube
ich völlig klar dass diese Erfolge groß
sind und die sollten wir auch anerkennen
herzlichen Dank Frau Präsident Thorsten
frei der Parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführer der cdu/csu-fraktion zu
Recht geehrt sagt er wurde Merkel und
überhand durch schwierige Zeiten geführt
als die Zeremonie am vergangenen Montag
im Schloss Bellevue war zur
Ordensverleihung der konnte Angela
Merkel rund 20 Gäste einladen sie nun
vor allem Weggefährten ein ehemalige
Kanzleramtsminister wie Thomas de
Maizière oder Helge braun aus der
aktuellen CDU und
CSU-Führung war niemand dabei Ausführung
verliehen und sie damit für Ihre
persönlichen Leistungen geehrt und ich
möchte diesen Job der AFD auch dafür
nutzen um hier in aller Klarheit zu
sagen wir gratulieren Frau Merkel ganz
herzlich zu dieser schönen Auszeichnung
meine Damen und
allein dass sie als konservative
Politikerin Kollege Korte 2015 die
Grenzen nicht geschlossen hat sondern
dass sie europäisch und rechtskonform
gehandelt hat dass sie Menschen die vor
Krieg Folter und Tod geflohen ist hier
den Schutz ermöglicht hat allein das
rechtfertigt diese Auszeichnung schon
man kann
anderer Meinung sein aber selbst dann
gebietet ist bei allen politischen
Differenzen der Respekt und der
bürgerliche Anstand dass man zu dieser
Ehrung gratuliert meine Damen und Herren
und nicht dass wir uns falsch verstehen
meine Fraktion und ich selbst haben
vieles was frau Merkel gemacht hat und
vor allem was sie nicht gemacht hat
immer hart und deutlich kritisiert ich
persönlich habe vier
bundestagswahlkämpfe hinter mir bei
denen ich mich mit den völlig
unzureichenden Positionen von CDU und
CSU auseinandergesetzt haben und
explizit dafür Wahl kämpft habe dass
Frau Merkel eben nicht Bundeskanzlerin
wird
zugegebenermaßen nicht mit ganz
durchschlagenem Erfolg aber
ich habe also schon demokratisch hier
gegen Frau Merkel und ihre Politik
gestritten da gab es ihre Partei die AFD
noch gar nicht und da war ihre Ikone
Herr gauland noch ein ganz braves CDU
Mitglied aus Hessen und deswegen
erzählen Sie mir nichts vom
demokratischen Diskurs und
Auseinandersetzung mit der
unzureichenden Politik der Union meine
Damen und Herren
erstaunlich aber ist
dass ich auch so mancher Parteifreund
bis heute offenbar nicht dazu
durchringen kann frau Merkel die
Kollegialität Verbundenheit und den
Respekt zu geben die diese Auszeichnung
ja irgendwie abverlang Friedrich Merz
verweigerte vor laufender Kamera ein
Glückwunsch selbst auf viermaliges
nachfragen wie klein kann das Caro
werden Herr frei das frage ich sie
und ja Angela Merkel hat Fehler gemacht
keine kleinen und nicht wenige sie trägt
große Verantwortung für die
verhängnisvolle Abhängigkeit
Deutschlands von russischen gasfrau von
Storch und hielt bis zuletzt C an Nord
Stream 2 fest von der sträflichen
Vernachlässigung der Digitalisierung
über die herabwirtschaft über das
herabwirtschaften der Deutschen Bahn bis
hin zum verschlafen der Energiewende
unter diesen Versäumnissen leidet
Deutschland bis heute schmerzlich all
diese Kritikpunkte meine Damen und
Herren von der Union können sie aber
doch nicht meinen Herr frei denn diese
Politik haben sie ja volle Kanne
mitgetragen dann stellt sich die Frage
was passt kein Arzt und Herrn Linnemann
nicht es ist ja in den letzten zwei
Minuten ihrer Rede angeklungen passt
Ihnen nicht dass Sie als Kanzlerin nach
einer Phase der Irrungen dann doch aus
Fukushima die richtigen Konsequenzen
gezogen haben und auf den Atomausstieg
eingeschränkt ist passt ihnen nicht dass
Frau Merkel trotz persönlich anderer
Meinung die Größe hatte die Abstimmung
zur Ehe für alle freizugeben
denn wenn es 2017 nach ihrer Fraktion
gegangen der nach zwei Drittel ihrer
Fraktion hätten wir bis heute für Schule
und lesbische Paare ein Eheverbot meine
Damen und Herren
oder Miss gönnen Sie hier dass sie nach
all den Jahren der Verantwortung als
Abgeordnete Ministerin CDU-Vorsitzende
und Bundeskanzlerin selbstbestimmt und
sauber aus der Tür gekommen ist oder ist
es dann am Ende eben doch frei die
Flüchtlingspolitik die Sie Angela Merkel
bis heute nachtragen und deshalb ihr das
Großkreuz nur so halb gönnen
und da möchte ich Ihnen sagen Herr frei
das Kreuz mit dem Großkreuz in ihrem
Fraktionssaal befindet sich ja auch ein
großes Kreuz es ist ein spannendes
interessantes und wie ich finde
ausgesprochen inspirierendes Kunstwerk
das dort seit vielen vielen Jahren hängt
es ist geschaffen vom Bildhauer Markus
Daum aus Radolfzell am schönen Bodensee
ihre Fraktion schreibt dazu selbst auf
Ihre Homepage Zitat die CDU CSU-Fraktion
begreift das Kreuz als geistiges und
spirituelles Fundament das uns trägt
darum versammeln wir uns unter diesem
Kreuz Zitat Ende ich finde wenn man die
Bedeutung dieses Kreuzes sich
vergegenwärtig und zwar künstlerisch wie
auch religiös dann sollte es helfen das
gemeinsame konstruktiv zu suchen und
nicht das Trennende auch bei der
Verleihung eines großkretes in
besonderer Ausfertigung und das würde
ich mir von ihnen in diesem Haus
insgesamt mehr wünschen gerade in
Abgrenzung
zu diesen polemischen spalterischen
Demagogen die diese aktuelle Stunde
beantragt haben ganz ganz herzlichen
Dank meine Damen und
unseren Kindern für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen er hat auch Kritik
formuliert an einigen
Entscheidungen in der Amtszeit von
Angela Merkel und trotzdem der
Bundeskanzlerin zur Auszeichnung hängt
gratuliert und konnte sich den ein oder
anderen Seitenhieb in Richtung Union
nicht sparen also jetzt hören wir in
dieser aktuellen Stunde für die Linke
Jan Korte den Parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführer Thorsten frei das ist ja
ein Steffen Seibert
ähnlichkeitswettbewerb hier gewesen was
wir vorgebracht haben also das war schon
nicht schlecht also das war ganz gut
also zunächst einmal er hat die AFD
diese aktuelle Stunde beantragt um über
Orten zu reden die gibt sich hier
vermeintlich ordentlich kritisch das
lassen wir mal so dahingestellt ich
denke so also eine Kreuze oder
ritterkreuze verleihen da finden sie
wahrscheinlich ganz in Ordnung aber
deswegen möchte ich hier über andere
reden das einzige was sie ja nicht
gefällt das Angela Merkel den Orden
bekommt und die haben einen in jeder
Hinsicht pathologisches Verhältnis
dieser Frau da würde ich wirklich mal
klinisch drüber nachdenken was da
eigentlich passiert ist deswegen möchte
ich da jetzt nicht weiter darauf
eingehen also wir wissen jetzt nun alle
dass am 17 April die ehemalige
Bundeskanzlerin ich will das noch mal in
der ganzen Schönheit zitieren das
Großkreuz des Verdienstordens der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland in besonderer
Ausführung bekommen hat
es ist insofern relativ bizarrer als die
Bundeskanzlerin ich habe das noch mal
nachgeguckt bereits 1996 das Große
Verdienstkreuz bekommen hat dann 2008 da
war sie dann zum Bundeskanzlerin das
Großkreuz des Verdienstordens man fragt
sie hatte die verloren oder was warum
muss das jetzt noch einer sein ich finde
das schon relativ viel zahlen man muss
sich das mal wirklich reinziehen jetzt
mal wirklich ihr ehemaliger
Außenminister verleiht seiner ehemaligen
Chefin nur Orden das ist doch gerade zu
absurd das wäre so als wenn meine
Mitarbeiter in meinem Büro mir einen
Orden anhängen würden weil ich so ein
toller Chef bin das ist natürlich eine
aber witzige Katze
ja ich möchte ich möchte ich möchte
Liebe sozial Liebe total Demokratie ist
das eigentlich eure Kanzlerin oder was
das hat ja offenbar eure Bundeskanzlerin
gewesen sein ich möchte dazu folgen
argumentieren und es gibt natürlich bei
dieser ordensverlängerung zwei Dinge die
also ich außerordentlich erfreulich
finde das ist einmal
zunächst dass ich die AFD darüber
aufregt das ist ja immer gut aber jetzt
sage ich Ihnen was Kollege frei weil sie
so schön lächeln besonders gut finde ich
an dieser Ordensverleihung das März
Linnemann und frei nicht zur Party
eingeladen worden sind das finde ich das
besonders gute das muss man ja auch
einfach mal so anerkennen ich möchte
aber zum dritten zu dieser interessanten
ordensfrage folgende grundsätzliche
Anmerkung Mann ich finde wir sollten das
heute vielleicht doch schon mal nutzen
und hier vielleicht mal eine Sache auf
den Weg bringen nämlich diese Unkultur
dass sich die politische Elite in diesem
Land gegenseitig Orden umhängt das halte
ich für völlig aus der Zeit gefallen und
das waren alle in aller Klarheit in
aller Klarheit zu sagen denn ja in der
DDR davon zu kommen stehen die hat eine
8000 verschiedene Orten ja also da wurde
jeden Tag jemand ausgezeichnet und
deswegen habe ich aus den Erzählungen
der älteren genossen meine
schlussfolgung rausgezogen und halte das
auch modisch sinnvoll aber ich will noch
mal ernsthaft dazu sagen jetzt
ernsthafter sagen wie wirkt das
eigentlich auf die Leute in den
Feuerwehren in den Kleingartenvereinen
für die ehrenamtlichen Bürgermeister und
anderen wenn jemand einen Orden verdient
hat dann die aber nicht die politische
Elite dieses Landes und ist ausgegangen
und da ist da ich meine wie ich finde
einleuchtenden Argumente auch mit Zahlen
unterlegen möchte möchte ich Ihnen
folgendes noch mitteilen also allein in
der letzten Wahlperiode haben 3,5% der
Abgeordneten das Bundesverdienstkreuz
bekommen also Otto Fricke z.B
Glückwunsch du redest ja auch noch dazu
drei 3,5 % und zwar für ihre
ehrenamtliche Arbeit es gibt laut
statischen Bundesamt 17 Millionen
Ehrenamtler in diesem Land von denen
haben allerdings wir haben das sehr
genau ausgerechnet in den letzten zwei
Jahren lediglich
1250 ein bundesverdienstordnung bekommen
was
0,007 % ist ich finde das ist ein
Ungleichgewicht wenn man sich überlegt
mit welchen Privilegien wie viel Geld
wir hier verdienen mit was für fetten
Schlitten wir hier durch die Gegend
fahren können was wir für Freikarten
haben da müssen wir uns nicht noch
gegenseitig Orden Umhängen das haben
andere vor Ort verdient um das auch ganz
klar zu sagen
so so und ja ja es ist wirklich an sich
ein absolutes Thema das ist schon
richtig aber ich will das schon noch mal
sagen weil ich möchte meine wie ich
finde gelungenen Ausführungen auch
gelungen
abschließen und möchte möchte den ich
möchte ich möchte den ich möchte den
französischen Außenminister
aristibrieren hier zitieren der hat
nämlich 1926 zu diesem Thema alles
gesagt ich zitiere was ist ein Ort ein
kostensparender Gegenstand der es
ermöglicht mit wenig Metall viele
Eitelkeit zu befriedigen genauso sollten
wir mit diesen ordent Frank umgehen
vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
ja dass die Meinung hier von Jan Korte
für die Linke der Parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer und gerade zu Beginn
seiner Rede hatte er die stärksten
Reaktion tatsächlich das konnte man hier
im Saal verfolgen vor allem bei der
SPD-Fraktion hervorgerufen und deswegen
von ihm auch die Bemerkung man könnte ja
fast meinen Richtungen Sozialdemokraten
das sei ihre Kanzlerin gewesen auch an
Otto Fricke hat er sich schon gewonnen
der FDP Mann der tatsächlich wir haben
mal schnell nachgeschaut 2021 des
Bundesverdienstkreuz zumindest bekommen
hat frau Präsidentin nur weil man das
mal falsch bezeichnet auch manches kann
ein Orden sein ohne dass er irgendwo
ausgesprochen worden ist auch wenn es
manche gibt die das für sich selber dann
tun müssen Herr Kollege mein Leben
Kolleginnen und Kolle das war ja nun
sehr spaßig aber wenn wir mal versuchen
ein wenig darüber nachzudenken worüber
wir heute reden dann gibt es den Versuch
diese Ordensverleihung politisch
auszuwerten es gibt den Versuch zu sagen
wir reden es über die Frage was ein
Orden sozusagen nicht sein soll die
politische Klasse wir reden über Neid
und ähnliches mehr aber wir reden doch
über ein Thema eigentlich nicht dass wir
beim Thema Ordensverleihung eher mal
ansprechen sollten und auf dass ich uns
einfach mal bringen möchte nämlich die
Frage mit der wir Deutschen uns so
unglaublich schwer tun nämlich Danke zu
sagen einfach mal Danke zu sagen zu
sagen da ist jemand den ich politisch
nicht mag mit dem ich auch menschlich
möglicherweise wirklich nicht viel über
einen habe der aber einen enormen
Einsatz über das normale Maß hinaus und
übrigens Herr Kollege konnte genauso
auch genauso auch wie der Feuerwehrmann
genauso wie die Notärztin gemacht hat
und dann ist es wie ich finde etwas
Gutes wenn ein Land in der Lage ist das
sowohl beim das darf ich sagen Otto
Normalverbraucher zu tun als auch bei
einer Bundeskanzlerin und das möchte ich
ausdrücklich sagen dieses ist auch ein
Dank
aber es ist eben kein Denkmal es ist
keine Heiligsprechung noch nicht einmal
eine Seligsprechung sondern es geht
darum dass da jemand etwas getan und da
möchte ich dann doch bei der Person bei
dem Menschen gar nicht so sehr bei der
Politikerin auf etwas hinweisen und dann
sage ich auch Herr Kollege Korte ja dann
mache ich auch Werbung für die von ihnen
so genannte politische Klasse wobei ich
glaubte in einem Land zu leben wo es aus
meiner Sicht keine Klassen gibt diese
Frau diese Frau ja ich weiß für sie gibt
es Klassen weil sie sich in einer
besseren Klasse sehen als der Rest das
mag ja alles zu sein ich sehe das nicht
so aber zu Angela Merkel zurückkommen
viele hier aus allen Fraktionen haben
einen enormen Einsatz für diese
Demokratie und das gilt auch für Angela
Merkel und zwar sowohl für diese
Demokratie als auch für die sehr kurze
Demokratie am Ende der DDR das hat sie
getan bis von frühmorgens bis spät
abends und jeder der anwesend der sich
jetzt erlebt hat hat erlebt was das ist
das dabei England ich vieles war was mir
überhaupt nicht gefallen hat dass ich
selber im Jahr in den Jahren 2009 bis
2013 Dinge erlebt habe die mir das dies
Bewusstsein eines Machiavellismus noch
mal verdeutlicht haben das stimmt aber
das hat doch mit der Frage wofür man als
Gesellschaft wofür unser Staatsoberhaupt
und nicht ein ehemaliger Außenminister
sondern einer von der Bundesversammlung
gewählter Mann der Staatsoberhaupt des
Landes sagt im Vertretung für alle
anderen wir sagen hier danke für diesen
Einsatz das hat er doch da getan und
meine Damen und Herren das sollten wir
immer wieder klar machen Dankbarkeit
heißt nicht
Zeiten etwas für richtig oder für falsch
denn die Frage von Politik ist doch fast
nie richtig oder falsch wenn wir ganz
ehrlich sind es geht um die Frage besser
oder schlechter und wenn wir dann mal
kurz den Blick wegnehmen von unserem
unserer eigenen Nabelschau und mal
gucken was das Ausland darüber denkt
welche Diskussionen wir hier führen dann
bekommen sie Kopfschütteln weil die
meisten europäischen Nationen um uns rum
sagen ja natürlich hat die Fehler
gemacht ja natürlich sind da Dinge
falsch gelaufen aber wenn wir sehen was
Sie geleistet haben was sie gemacht hat
das hätte viel schlechter sein können
und das werden wir immer wieder uns
bewusst machen müssen auch in den
nächsten Jahren gerade in einer
zeitenwände wir glauben heute wir machen
alles richtig und wir werden
möglicherweise schon in einem Jahr sagen
oh das war falsch und in Richtung der
AFD vielleicht zum Schluss noch eine
Anmerkung bevor ich natürlich gerne noch
mal ein kleines Zitat machen will hat
sich die AFD eigentlich überlegt wie sie
mit der Tatsache umgeht dass sie auch
einen Teil ihrer Existenz dieser Frau zu
verdanken hat ja so und jetzt überlegt
euch noch mal ob man nicht statt mit
einer populistischen Aktuellen Stunde
reagieren sollte sondern mit einer
gewissen Demut ob der Frage ob man im
Leben alles richtig macht und das Zitat
zum Schluss kommt aus Faust 1 und es
passt wie ich finde wie die Faust aufs
Auge denn wir alle werden nicht wissen
ob wir was dem weil bei dem was wir tun
immer richtig regieren immer richtig
koalieren
mit jedem Morgen dass ich nicht brauche
fürs römische Reich zu sorgen ich halte
es wenigstens für reichlich gewinnen
dass ich nicht Kaiser oder Kanzler bin
danke
war das für die FDP-Fraktion Einfach mal
DANKE sagen so hat er seine Rede
begonnen und
die AFD hat jetzt noch mal die
Gelegenheit
ihren Personen von Beatrix von Storch
hier zu sprechen
und Herren der cdu-
vorsitzig März hat erklärt ich zitiere
ich habe die Verleihung des großkreuzes
an Angela Merkel nicht zu bewerten
deutlicher hätte er kaum machen können
was er von der Beweihräucherung seiner
Nachfolgerin hält sie wissen welches
Desaster Merkel hinterlassen hat und wir
wissen es auch nur Sie können es nicht
sagen wie aber schon der Historiker Nil
Ferguson bilanzierte era Merkel so
Merkels Kanzlerschaft war ein kolossaler
Ausfall Merkel hat keine großen
Leistungen vorzuweisen dafür aber viele
Fehlentscheidungen britische Höflichkeit
die dieser Streuseln Folgen von ihrer
Politik kennen wir Massenmigration
Migrantengewalt gespaltenes Europa Euro
Weichwährung Schulden und John
explodierende pleise
Spitzenreiter bei steuern und
Energiekosten kaputte Infrastruktur
abgewirtschaftete Bundeswehr ruiniert
das Gesundheitssystem das ist Merkels
katastrophale Bilanz und dafür verleiht
ihr der Bundespräsident jetzt die
Sonderstufe des großkretes mit Lohrberg
Hans bis jetzt haben diese Auszeichnung
erhalten wir haben es schon gehört
Konrad Adenauer der gründungskanzler und
Helmut Kohl der Kanzler der Einheit um
die Bedeutung des Ordens noch zu
ermessen können wir aber auch uns
ansehen wer den Orden nicht bekommen hat
Ludwig Erhard der Vater der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft Willy Brandt der
friedenspolitiker und Nobelpreisträger
oder Helmut Schmidt der echte
Krisenmanager diese großen Kanzler haben
den Orden nicht bekommen und jetzt
Merkel das ist so wie der
Literaturnobelpreis für Jan Böhmermann
eine fast
und ist es nicht schizophren die SPD
entschuldigt alle Probleme in Lampel
heute mit den Altlasten aus der
merkelzeit und gleichzeitig kommt dann
Herr Steinmeier SPD und überreicht ihr
den höchsten Orden den nicht mal Willy
Brandt bekommen hat kann etwas die
selbstverzwergung der SPD besser
symbolisieren als
Steinmeiers Bereitschaft sich in
vorauseilendem Gehorsam der merkelten
Geschichtsklitterung zu unterwerfen
die ehemalige Bundeskanzlerin lässt sich
von ihrem ehemaligen Außenminister den
sie in das Amt des Bundespräsidenten
befördert hat in einem kreishand
verlesener Merkel Jana zu einem der drei
großen Kanzler der deutschen
Nachkriegsgeschichte ausrufen der
Bundespräsident hat in seiner ansonsten
natürlich komplett
substanzlosen Lobrede auf seine
ehemalige Chefin eine derartige verbale
Schleimspur bezogen gezogen auf der
hätte Merkel ungebremst und problemlos
von Bellevue direkt in die Uckermark
rutschen können aber egal wie viele
Orden noch kommen die Merkel Mythen
stürzen in sich zusammen ein Merkel
Mythos sie war ja so beliebt sie war so
beliebt dass die Union in ihrer Zeit von
38% auf 24 abgestürzt ist und sie war so
beliebt dass 71% der deutschen sie auf
kein Fall zurück haben wollen zweite
merkelmythos sie war ja so bescheiden
sie war so bescheiden dass sie ihre
katastrophale Kanzlerschaft nun auf eine
Ebene mit der Gründung und dem Aufbau
der Republik und der deutschen
Wiedervereinigung stellt mal ganz
abgesehen von dem gigantomaren
Kanzleramt was sie bauen wollte das
Gegenteil von Bescheidenheit trifft es
Merkels Kanzlerschaft steht für
krankhafte Egomanie sie hat sich immer
nur mit Ja-Sagern und Versagern umgeben
so auch bei der Ordensverleihung sie
lässt sich neben Adenauer und Kohl in
den
cdu-olympheben und legt den
CDU-Vorsitzenden nicht ein die Frau hat
uns
gerade war geladen waren aber ihre
politischen Gehilfen Ursula von der
Leyen Bundeswehr an die Wand gefahren
Annette Schavan dr würde wegen
vorsätzlicher Täuschung aberkannt Peter
Altmaier verantwortlich für das
asylchars und die dümmste Energiepolitik
der Welt aber immerhin die Gelegenheit
ist nun da mit der Aufarbeitung der
merkeljahre zu beginnen merkel war keine
schwäbische Hausfrau sie war nicht
Mutter Teresa und sie war nicht die
Verteidigung Verteidigerin des freien
Westens sie war Macht besessen
inkompetent und Deutschland und Europa
waren wir völlig egal ihr Motto war
immer nach mir die Sinnflut das wirklich
positives der merkelzeit wurde gerade
schon erwähnt ist die Gründung der AFD
ohne Merkel kaum denkbar wir werden die
Wunden der merkelzeit in unserer
Nationen heilen aber wir werden nie
vergessen was diese Frau an Deutschland
verbrochen hat und Frau Merkel
vielleicht tun sie eins und widmen
diesen Orten den vielen Toten und
Hinterbliebenen ihrer Migrationspolitik
die haben verdient
[Applaus]
das Wort hat Katrin Budde für die
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
Großkreuz des Verdienstordens nicht
entwerten Verleihung nur an
herausragende Persönlichkeiten der
deutschen Geschichte so ist das volle
Thema und wenn man das Thema ernst
nehmen würde müsste man ja als erstes
Fragen und warum sagen Sie das jetzt
von der afd-fraktion das ist doch
gelebte Realität
Konrad Adenauer als nachkriegskanzler
Helmut Kohl als Kanzler der Europa
mitgebaut hat und zwar Wiedervereinigung
Kanzler war Angela Merkel die die erste
Frau und geborene ostdeutsche im Amt war
die Deutschland gemeinsam mit ihren
jeweiligen koalitionspartnerinnen über
16 Jahre durch viele Krisen geführt hat
die Deutschland zu internationale
Anerkennung geführt hat die den Mut
hatte Deutschland gegen große Teile ihre
eigenen Partei zu modernisieren
eigentlich fehlen in dieser Reihe noch
einige unter anderem er ist schon
mehrmals gesagt worden ja Willy Brandt
der mit seiner Ostpolitik zur
Entspannung und Versöhnung beigetragen
hat nun haben wir ja aber inzwischen die
Reden der AFD gehört und das ist
offensichtlich und hörbar geworden was
sie meinten nicht dass wir das nicht
geahnt hätten aber es ist jetzt
ausgesprochen die taz hat in Ihrer
Kommentierung über die Verleihung an die
Bundeskanzlerin ade Angela Merkel sich
eines klugen Instruments bedient eines
pro und contra-kommentars hat sie die
Auszeichnung verdient Fragezeichen ja
hat sie und nein hat sie nicht überzogen
und pointiert unter Weglassung aller
Abwägungen stehen da beide Meinungen
sich gegenüber die geneigte Leserin ist
damit aufgefordert und gezwungen sich
selber zu entscheiden nach reiflicher
Abwägung und auch im Wissen um Fehler
die insbesondere im Rückspiegel von
denen die sie zum Teil mitgemacht haben
als Fehler betrachtet werden bin ich
persönlich entschieden ja hat sie und
ich war nie bekennender merkel-fan und
man muss auch nicht alle ihre
Entscheidungen
unterstützen man muss nicht zufrieden
sein ich bin es durchaus nicht habe in
der Sache oft andere Positionen
vertreten mir andere Entscheidungen
gewünscht aber sie hat sich sehr wohl
und ganz entscheidend um Deutschland
verdient gemacht als Frauen der Politik
seit 33 Jahren in Mandaten kenne ich das
Geschäft selber sehr gut und weiß um die
zusätzlichen Türken sich in einer
Männerwelt zu behaupten Spitzen gegen
die Verleihung des großkreuzes an Frau
Bundeskanzlerin ade habe ich bisher aus
der CDU auch nur von Männern gehört
sie galt wohl in der CDU für viele lange
als betriebsunfallen Respekt Frau
Bundeskanzlerin dass sie durchgehalten
haben
erinnern Sie sich vielleicht an das Bild
als Horst Seehofer das ist die CSU
Angela Merkel auf dem Parteitag der CSU
hat während seiner gesamten Rede stehen
lassen manchmal sind es solche Bilder
und die kleinen Gesten die mehr über
Menschen sagen mir fallen da noch viele
ähnliche ein
in 16 Jahren kanzlerinnenschaft hat
Angelika Merkel vier US-Präsidenten für
französische
Staatspräsidenten fünf Premierminister
Großbritanniens acht italienische
Ministerpräsidenten erlebt sie können
selber zählen wie viele davon Männer
waren die gegangen sind sie war
respektiert und anerkannt und sie hat
selbstbestimmt wann sie ihr Amt verlässt
sie von der AFD Frau Storch hat es noch
mal bewiesen halten aber offensichtlich
Stil nicht für eine Umgangsform sondern
glauben dass es das längere Ende einer
Schaufel ist
und sie haben in ihrer Debatte das
Gegenteil mit ihrer Debatte das
Gegenteil von dem erreicht was sie
wollten sogar die cdu/csu musste sich
öffentlich-würdigend und positiv zu
ihrer Kanzlerin Merkel verhalten
das ist auch gut so meine Kanzlerin
Angela Merkel weiß nie aber ich habe
großen sehr großen Respekt vor ihr als
kluge Frau in einer Männerwelt als
abbieten und durchsetzungsstarke
Politikerin als eine Kanzlerin die
Europa zusammengehalten hat die
Deutschland an der Spitze durch küssen
geführt hat und die sich um Deutschland
verdient gemacht hat und das ist richtig
dass ihr das Großkreuz verliehen wurde
sagt Kathrin wurde hier für die
SPD-Fraktion
und man hat den Eindruck in dieser
aktuellen Stunde der größere Zuspruch
für diese Verleihung des Verdienstordens
kam bisher tatsächlich eher von den
Sozialdemokraten hören wir jetzt für die
CSU Dorothee Kolleginnen und Kollegen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren wie
entstehen aktuelle Stunden sie müssen
sich das ungefähr so vorstellen an
Beginn einer Sitzungswoche überlegen
sich die Fraktionen beantragen wir eine
Aktuelle Stunde ja oder nein die AFD
lässt sich immer sehr viel Zeit und dann
entscheiden Sie welches Thema eignet
sich in jeder Woche für Hass für Häme
für politische Spaltung und für eine
Vergiftung der Gesellschaft
und
das Spannende ist sie werden jede Woche
irgendwie fündig die Woche habe ich mir
überlegt was geht diese Woche aber nein
wahnsinnig kreativ und das muss heute
ein Feiertag der AFD sein sie werden
überall die Korken hören weil diese Hass
und Hetze Debatte fällt auch noch auf
den 20 April herzlichen Glückwunsch AFD
absolut ja muss man ganz offen
ansprechen was Sie mit unserem Land
machen wollen
genauso ist es das Großkreuz des
Verdienstordens ist so besonders weil es
praktisch nicht verliehen wird wie
angesprochen bislang nur an
herausragende Persönlichkeiten der
Geschichte und sie haben versucht die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von Rechtsaußen
die höchste Auszeichnung unseres Landes
zu diskreditieren sie sind diejenigen
die hier Demokratie diskreditiert die
unsere Gesellschaft Tag für Tag Spalten
wollen und die wirklich nur mit Hass
Hetze und Polemik hier in diesem Haus
aufwarten wollen das werden wir nicht
zulassen
und deswegen ich weiß dass es die
intellektuell total überfordern wird
trotzdem ein paar Fragen an sie von wem
stammt folgender Satz sie ist die Stimme
für Menschenrechte weltweit stammt von
Barack Obama kein geringerer als der
US-Präsident der das über die deutsche
Bundeskanzlerin gesagt hat als er ihr
2011 die präsidential Metal of freedom
die Freiheitsmedaille und die höchste
zivile Auszeichnung der Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika verliehen hat aber
ich weiß dass sie mit Barack Obama auch
große Probleme haben
zweite Frage wie oft hat die Kanzlerin
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel die Liste
der mächtigsten Frauen der Welt im
volksmagazin angeführt das Ranking
passiert auf der öffentlichen
Wahrnehmung der wirtschaftlichen
Bedeutung Angela Merkel 14 Jahre lang in
die Liste der mächtigsten Personen der
Welt nicht nur Frauen sondern Personen
der Welt wurde Angela Merkel 9 mal
aufgenommen auch was fast keiner aus
ihren rein jemals in seinem Leben Gott
sei Dank erreichen wird und die dritte
Frage
wie viele Deutsche Persönlichkeiten der
Geschichte wurden vom Times Magazin
überhaupt jemals als Person of the Year
gewürdigt die Antwort ist außer Angela
Merkel keine die allererste Frau in 29
Jahren der 2015 diese Erde total wurde
und die erste deutsche seitwilly Brandt
auch dazu nachträglich noch herzlichen
Glückwunsch
fette Frage wie oft wie wurde Angela
Merkel auf dem zugehörigen Titelbild der
Zeitschrift bezeichnet Antwort als
chance of the free world die Kanzlerin
der freien Welt und die letzte Frage für
heute an Sie diese auch nicht
beantworten können wer hat denn unser
Land durch die großen globalen Krisen
der letzten Jahrzehnte geführt und nein
werden keiner dieser Krisen ist
Deutschland zusammengebrochen oder hätte
die Breite der Gesellschaft nicht
zusammengestanden richtig auch Angela
Merkel an dieser Stelle
wir hatten und die Bundesregierung hat
jetzt auch Herausforderungen aber wir
hatten auch in unseren Jahren
Herausforderungen
2007/2008 wählt Finanzkrise
Staatsschuldenkrise Griechenlands die
nicht nur Deutschland die die gesamte
Europäische Union vor riesige
Herausforderungen gestellt hat Angela
Merkel haben die Menschen in Europa
entscheidend zu verdanken dass der
Euroraum weiter Bestand hat dass Europa
insgesamt nicht auseinandergefallen ist
weil das war nämlich auch nicht so
einfach in diesen Jahren ja der
flüchtlingskrise ist angesprochen auch
tausende Menschen in Not haben Angela
Merkel ihr Überleben zu verdanken und in
der corona-krise 2020 hat schon seinen
Grund warum die Fernsehansprache der
Bundeskanzlerin zur Pandemie am 18 März
2020 zur Rede des Jahres insgesamt
gekrönt wurde also man sieht sie hat
wirklich in diesen letzten 16 Jahren so
viele Verdienste und warum weil ein
typisches Markenzeichen von ihr immer
war Menschen in Angst die Sorgen zu
nehmen Mut zuzusprechen ein
Gemeinschaftsgefühl Solidarität
herzustellen alles Parameter die sie
noch nicht mal buchstabieren können
und diese Markenzeichen der altkanzlerin
sind Vernunft kombiniert mit Haltung
kombiniert mit Einfühlungsvermögen etwas
was ich ihnen auch komplett abspreche
und was sie mit Beantragung der
Aktuellen Stunde auch wieder bestätigt
haben sie steht für Multilateralismus
wie keine andere und ich sage Ihnen es
wurde schon mal vor Jahren ein Lied über
sie geschrieben wenn man es wohl wollen
sagen würde sie werden es nie erreichen
die Ärzte haben damals gesagt deine
Gewalt ist nur ein stummer Schrei nach
Liebe deine Springerstiefel sehen sich
nach Zärtlichkeit sehr traurig was Sie
heute hier abgezogen haben
aber Dorothee Bär hier für die CSU
hat für sich in ihrer Rede doch viele
Verweise und viele Punkte gefunden und
viele historische Einordnungen und ihr
Lob für Angela Merkel so deutlich
gemacht
Leon Eckert jetzt für die Grünen sehr
geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ich möchte an die
Rede von meiner von Frau Bär anschließen
und noch einen Punkt hinzufügen
wen trifft denn die AFD mit ihrem Geräte
sie kritisieren die
migrationsentscheidungen die
Entscheidungen 2015 und wer wird denn
hier fertig gemacht von ihnen wer wird
angegriffen es werden doch die
Helferinnen und Helfer
kritisiert die wenn der Alarm gehen
rausgehen die Unterkünfte eingerichtet
haben die da waren als Unterkünfte
aufgebaut werden müssen das sind die
Helfer vom Roten Kreuz das sind die
Helfer von dem Maltesern von den
Johannitern von der Feuerwehr vom ASB
die da waren die jedem helfen egal von
welcher Herkunft die Unterkünfte
aufbauen die Verpflegung organisieren
und die deswegen auch geehrt werden
durch unseren Staat die auch eine
Würdigung erhalten die auch einen Orden
erhalten deswegen und mit der mit dieser
aktuellen Stunden haut ihr diesen
Menschen eine rein und sagt es ist alles
wertlos was ihr macht aber ich glaube
was die demokratische Mitte in diesem
Parlament eint ist dass wir anerkennen
wenn Menschen sich einsetzen für die
Gemeinschaft über dem normalen Maß und
ein Orden ist ein Stück Blech es ist
einfach nur in einer Kiste schön
dekoriert's Blech und das Wichtige ist
glaube ich nicht der Orden oder ob er
dick an der Uniform ist ich bin auch
kein Fan von Projekt Feuerwehruniform
als Christbaum sondern es geht doch um
die Würdigung die Würdigung die mit
diesem Akt verbunden ist dass wir
jemanden danken wenn er da war jetzt im
a Teil den Helferinnen und Helfern die
in ihrer Freizeit hochgefahren sind und
geholfen haben Menschen in Not die
Unterkünfte aufbauen wenn Menschen in
Not sind und darum geht es doch wenn wir
Orden verleihen und diesen Orden hat
auch jetzt die Bundeskanzlerin ade
bekommen eine Würdigung von unserem
Staat dass sie da war in den letzten 16
Jahren sich für das Gemeinwohl
eingesetzt hat und das ich denke schon
über das normale Maß einer Person
[Applaus]
vielleicht ist es aber auch etwas Neid
denn die AFD treibt diese Debatte
einzusetzen ist tropft ja so förmlich
raus und deswegen sind vielleicht auch
der ein oder andere Reichsbürger in der
AFD dann doch drin um sich fantasietitel
und eigene Orden zu schaffen in einem
eigenen Staat von einem Prinzen
vielleicht ausgestellt vielleicht ist
das der leichtere Weg um einen Orden zu
kommen
ich bin sehr dafür dass man Würdigungen
ausspricht man kann auch gerne in Orden
dran sein gerne auch bandschneienfähig
ich glaube der eine Markt der andere mag
es nicht aber es gibt auch Orden die
werden verliehen da ist jetzt keine
Würdigung dabei Ministerpräsidenten
bekommen zum Beispiel direkt zum Anzug
den Orden einfach automatisch dazu das
ist natürlich schön wenn man danach ein
Fehler macht dann kann da ist er schon
mal dran aber da würde ich sagen solche
Mechanismen und die kann man kritisch
hinterfragen ob man wirklich automatisch
zu Amtsantritt schon Orden bekommen soll
oder ob nicht danach die Würdigung das
Wichtigere ist und sozusagen die Bilanz
für den Einsatz
und auch der proportsorden der ja auch
schon angesprochen ist den es hier im
Bundestag gab Gott sei Dank ist er
abgeschafft worden ich denke das war ein
wichtiger Schritt ist so ein Punkt wo
man sagt muss das sein dass man so in
die in die Reihen der
Bundestagsabgeordneten mal ein paar
Orden reinwirft ich glaube da kann doch
das kann doch jeder von uns
selbstbewusst sagen wenn wir uns für
unser Land eingesetzt haben dann kann
ich danach dann vielleicht auch einen
Orden bekommen und muss nicht auf den
proports Orden hier äh hoffen den es
früher gab und wozu das führt ist
Nüsslein Sauter hatten beide auch
bundesverdienstordnung Herr Nüsslein
auch wahrscheinlich durch diesen kurze
Hort und was da dann danach rauskommen
kann dass kann man ja auch sehen
deswegen achtung bei der ordenswahl für
verdienstte und nicht per Post nicht bei
Amtsantritt einfach so dazu sondern als
Würdigung für den Einsatz für unsere
Gemeinschaft
[Applaus]
ich komme zurück zu den Wahlen wir sind
kurz vor Schließung der wahlungen ich
werde nach dem nächsten Redner die
Wahlurnen oder die Wahl beenden die ohne
schließen
15:57 Uhr ist die Zeit für die Wahlen
abgelaufen sollte also jemand noch nicht
die Gelegenheit gehabt haben zu wählen
dann möge er sich jetzt oder auch sie
auf den Weg machen
Präsidentin Petra Pau im Hintergrund
laufen nämlich zwei Wahlgänge wenn sie
jetzt erst zugeschaltet haben da geht es
um die Wahl eines Bundestags Vizes für
die Bundestagspräsidentin die AFD stellt
ja nach wie vor keinen bundestagsvize da
keiner der Kandidaten bis dann wir
erforderliche Mehrheit bekommen hat
heute tritt der afd-abgeordnete Tobias
Peter K an und dieser Wahlgang läuft im
Hintergrund genauso ein Wahlgang für
einen Mitglied da geht es auch um ein
Mitglied der afd-fraktion für das
parlamentarische kontrollleben dass die
Geheimdienste kontrolliert zurück in die
aktuelle Stunde am Rednerpult an
veroschka Jurisch für die FDP Verhalten
ob das ordensgesetz und seine
Ausführungsbestimmungen hier
ordnungsgemäß angewendet wurden aber das
ist eigentlich für uns als Parlament
nicht unser Job und mal ganz abgesehen
davon kann ich hier auch keinen Verstoß
erkennen wir können uns hier unterhalten
darüber ob man dieses Gesetz ändern
sollte ob man zum Beispiel auf die
ermessensvorschriften die da drin sind
ob man die reduzieren soll aber auch das
ist glaube ich wenig zielführend und
sinnvoll das ist natürlich in der Natur
der Sache einer Würdigung dass das auf
Grundlage von Ermessen erfolgt wozu ist
also das behaken was wir hier machen
denn eigentlich dann da es ist doch klar
geworden es geht ihnen nur um die
Demontage von Frau Merkel und das haben
ja auch diese unfassbaren Ausführung von
Frau Storch vorher klar gemacht und
deswegen komme ich zum zweiten Punkt die
Zielsetzung dieser Debatte ist peinlich
sie ist peinlich weil sie respektlos ist
und ein Kleingeistigkeit nicht zu
überbieten ist und ich habe gehört was
sie gerade gesagt haben man muss
man muss die Entscheidung des
Bundespräsidenten nicht mittragen jeder
von uns muss sie nicht mittragen aber
wir alle hier in diesem Hohen Haus
sollten doch den Anstand haben den
Anstand haben diese Würdigung zu
respektieren
sie von der AFD sie insinuieren dass
Frau Merkel den Orden nicht verdient
habe lassen Sie uns hier auch drüber
sprechen wir müssen nicht alle
Entscheidungen und alle politischen
Zielsetzungen die Frau Merkel Frau
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel damals verfolgt
hat expost oder auch ex ante mittragen
und man kann auch nicht wenn man 16
Jahre als Bundeskanzlerin gedient hat
alles immer richtig machen
aber es sollte uns gelingen die
Lebensleistung von Frau Bundeskanzlerin
außer Dienst Merkel zumindest in so weit
anzuerkennen dass wir jetzt nicht
darüber sprechen dass wir ihr die
Würdigung nicht zusprechen wollen die
mit diesem Orden verbunden sind oder in
Orden wo möglich sogar noch abzuerkennen
und da möchte ich auch auf das Diktum
von meinem Kollegen Fricke von der
Dankbarkeit und vom danke sagen
zurückkommen das ist doch wirklich
wichtig Frau Merkel hat seit 1991 seit
1991 Verantwortung in unserem Land
übernommen als Ministerin als MdB als
Parteivorsitzende als Kanzlerin und das
ist mit unglaublich viel persönlicher
Zurücknahme verbunden wir alle die wir
hier unten sitzen wir haben eine Ahnung
davon was das bedeutet wenn man seine
Familie nicht sieht wenn man seinen
Ehepartner nicht sieht wenn man wenig
Zeit für Freunde hat wenn man wenig Zeit
hat für sich selbst und sie hat das für
viele viele Jahre gemacht aber es geht
natürlich
es geht nicht nur um den Zeitablauf es
geht nicht nur um die persönlichen Opfer
die Frau Merkel im großen Maß erbracht
hat sondern es geht auch über die
Leistung und Frau Merkel hat uns durch
viele sehr komplexe Krisen geführt sie
hat unser Land würdevoll und in Anstand
vertreten und was was wenn man sich im
Ausland umschaut auch keine
Selbstverständlichkeit ist wenn ich an
gewisse andere Regierungschef und
Staatsoberhäupter in der Vergangenheit
und heute auch denke und ein weiterer
Punkt den sie auch nicht gesehen haben
es ist eine Respektlosigkeit auch
gegenüber den Wählerinnen und Wählern
die das Vertrauen der Regie der
Regierungen Merkel übertragen haben und
das muss doch auch gesehen werden also
lassen Sie uns jetzt bitte schnell diese
unwürdige und unsinnige in ihrer
Zielsetzung peinliche Debatte enden
von der AFD und das möchte ich hier
abschließen sagen sie haben sich auf
jeden Fall auch eine Auszeichnung
verdient sie erhalten von mir den
bundesverdienst Keks für puren
Populismus Berlin viel Spaß damit
war das für die FDP-Fraktion
ich komme zurück zu den Wahlen die Zeit
für die Wahlen bis 15 Uhr ist exakt
abgelaufen gibt es noch ein Mitglied des
Hauses welches seine Stimme nicht
abgeben konnte
ich bitte das jetzt zügig zu erledigen
wenn ich mich rechnen Sinne hatte ich
vor sechs Minuten das hier schon in den
Raum gestellt
ja die Bundestag ist viel zu Präsidentin
wartet noch ab es hat tatsächlich noch
ein Abgeordneter ausge aufgezeigt dass
noch seine Stimme fehlt die Ohren sind
hier im Flur das Reichstags aufgestellt
nach wie vor die Wahlgänge lange
geöffnet damit die Abgeordneten eben
entsprechend Zeit haben hierher zu
kommen ihre Stimme einzuwerfen aber alle
haben es dann doch nicht geschafft
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen seit
kurzem sprechen wir wieder einmal
häufiger von den ostdeutschen sie stehen
wieder mal im Mittelpunkt einer
Diskussion und dabei meine ich jetzt
nicht die Aussagen die uns letzte Woche
in den Zeitungen begegneten sondern die
Analyse eines Mannes die dieser kürzlich
in einem Buch verfasste Doc oschmanns
Bio Monographie der Osten eine
westdeutsche Erfindung beobachtet
analysiert und bestätigt ein denken was
andere durch ihre Worte offenbaren das
Buch rangiert aktuell auch Platz eins
der Spiegel Bestseller und ist nach zwei
Monaten bereits in der fünften Auflage
erschienen eine These ist dass wir
ostdeutschen eine Identität erhalten
haben die wir nicht selbstbestimmt haben
sondern die uns durch den Westen
lediglich zugeschrieben wird und dazu
zählen dass wir zu Populismus neigen
würden ein Mangel des
Demokratieverständnis hätten
auch zu verschwörungsmythen zugewandt
werden er führt dies in zahlreichen
Beispielen aus und ja diese Beispiele
reichen bis in die Gegenwart und ich
will an dieser Stelle gar nicht weiter
darauf eingehen ob es wirklich eine
Konstruktion ist oder nicht ich will
auch gar nicht ständig in Ost- und
westdeutsch unterscheiden denn uns ein
viel mehr als das uns trennt es gibt
aber ein Fakt der wirklich bemerkenswert
ist Dirk Oschmann ist selbst
ostdeutscher und gehört ein Berufsstand
an der für ostdeutsche wahrlich selten
ist er ist Professor an einer
Universität und es gibt nur sehr sehr
wenige Professoren die eine ostdeutsche
Biografie haben und es gibt
verhältnismäßig wenig ostdeutsche in
Führungsposition das ist ein Problem und
das hat historische Gründe die Eliten
die mit dem Aufbau unseres Landes nach
der Wiedervereinigung betraut waren
waren
westdeutschen Sachsen zum Beispiel haben
unsere Kooperationspartner aus Baden
Langenberg und auch später haben sie
eher ihresgleichen gefördert und den
tendenziell weniger Ostdeutsche und so
entstand an manchen Stellen eine
gläserne Decke und genau hier müssen wir
ansetzen und überlegen wie es uns besser
gelingen kann aus deutsche in
Führungspositionen Verantwortung zu
bringen Vielfalt und Diversität das
heißt eben auch ostdeutsche mitdenken
und wenn wir jetzt mal zurückkommen auf
die aktuelle Debatte dann müssen wir uns
auch mal genau das vor Augen führen das
ist doch noch umso erstaunlicher ist das
ist 16 Jahre lang eine ostdeutsche
Bundeskanzlerin gab und sie selber hat
ihre Herkunft dabei nicht in den
Vordergrund gestellt aber viele
Ostdeutsche sind stolz darauf wir sind
stolz auf ihre Leistungen die hier und
heute auch noch einmal zu Recht
gewürdigt worden
und vielleicht noch einmal zum Thema
erste
Bundeskanzlerin Dirk Oschmann schreibt
nämlich übrigens auch wenn es um das
Durchsetzungsvermögen und die
Karriereplanung ginge dann wiederum
hatten es ostdeutsche Frauen teilweise
gegenüber ihren männlichen Kollegen auch
leichter denn sie waren es gewohnt sich
zu behaupten dass die Beruf und Familie
miteinander in Einklang gebracht haben
und dass sie gleichermaßen auch in den
naturwissenschaftlichen Berufen präsent
waren und das nun auch eine Frau
Kanzlerin wurde das kann ich Ihnen
versichern das hat Frauen dann in Ost
und West gleichermaßen gefreut und unter
den meisten Frauen für größte
Bewunderung gesorgt ihre Führungsstärke
ihre internationalen und europäischen
Verdienste ihre Zuverlässigkeit dies
gilt es zu würdigen
und noch einmal zur Chronologie Konrad
Adenauer Helmut Kohl und Angela Merkel
die drei Bundeskanzler mit den längsten
Amtszeiten die drei herausragenden
Vorsitzenden der CDU und die drei Träger
des Großkreuz im Besonderen Ausführung
die vorangegangene Debatte hat doch
gezeigt dass niemand der sich ernsthaft
mit der deutschen Geschichte und Politik
Auseinandersetzungen diese Verleihung
auseinandersetzt diese Verleihung in
Frage stellt viel mehr nutzt die AFD zum
wiederholten Male eine Aktuelle Stunde
für plumpe Polemik für Populismus und
Hass ein letztes Mal wollen sie sich an
Angela Merkel abarbeiten eine Frau die
sie unabhängig jeder Objektivität zum
Feindbild ihrer Partei akoren haben das
ist und bleibt armselig
es sind Neid und Niedertracht die aus
ihren Redebeiträgen trotzen weil
Adenauer Kohl und Merkel so viel mehr
für Deutschland erreicht haben als die
gesamte AFD in Gänze jemals erreichen
wird
es lässt sich also zusammenfassen unter
Konrad Adenauer wurde die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland aus den Trümmern des Zweiten
Weltkrieges wieder aufgebaut und der
Helmut Kohl wurde das geteilte
Deutschland wieder vereint und unter
Angela Merkel wuchs zusammen was
zusammen gehört
sagt Christiane schenderlein hier für
die cdu/csu-fraktion aus Sachsen kommt
sie und hat ja auch einiges an
persönlichen Eindrücken und Erinnerungen
mit in ihre Rede eingebracht ich
schließe die Wahlen und bitte die
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer mit
der Auszählung zu beginnen die
Ergebnisse der beiden werden Ihnen
später bekannt gegeben wir sind noch
immer in der aktuell
noch mal nachtragen also das der
Abgeordnete der für die AFD als Kandidat
für das Parlamentarische Kontrollgremium
für die Geheimdienste antritt das ist
Bernd Schaffner
Präsident kandidiert für die AFD Tobias
der stärker die Auszählung wie gesagt
Verlauf der nächsten Stunde hier noch
erfahren ist letzte Redner in dieser
aktuellen Stunde irgendwie reinpasst
dass wir miteinander sprechen können und
wenn das in den letzten beiden
Wahlperioden der Fall war und man kommt
in diesen Raum rein und dann stellt man
sich vor und dann kommt die erste Frage
von einer Schülerin oder einem Schüler
und dann hieß es ganz häufig kennen Sie
die Angela Merkel und ich habe immer
gedacht kommen die mir immer mit dieser
Angela Merkel
und dann habe ich den verraten wisst ihr
eigentlich kann ich die gar nicht so gut
leiden
und habe gesagt ja ich habe aus meinem
Herzen keine Mördergrube gemacht ich
habe gesagt wisst ihr die gehört halt
auch nicht meiner Partei an und ich
finde sie verwaltet zu viel und sie gibt
dem Land keine Orientierung und sie hat
sich was ausgedacht dass wir über alles
eine Soße drüber macht und wenn wir als
SPD was von der solidarrente gesagt
haben dann hat sie plötzlich
lebensleistungsrente gesagt und wenn wir
gesagt haben wir brauchen eine
Mindestlohn dann hat sie gesagt eine
Lohn Untergrenze und gemeint hat sie
damit was ganz anderes gemacht hat sie
nichts und so weiter und so fort und
dann habe ich aber gesagt aber die Frau
ist hier mal gewählt die Frau steht
jeden Tag auf dient unserem Land und sie
hat als allererstes Respekt verdient für
das was sie geleistet hat
und das ist eben der Unterschied denn
das was Sie hier mit dieser Debatte
angezettelt haben ist meine Damen wenn
man das so sagen will und Herren der AFD
respektlos und so sind das auch von
ihnen gewohnt
ich war mit dem Kollegen von ihnen jetzt
auf Dienstreise der war eben dabei der
hat sich dann immer als Mitglied der AFD
vorgestellt einer konservativen Partei
oder wenn man wenn man hört dass sie was
sie in ihrer eigenen Kameras dann immer
rein sagen dann stehen sie ganz häufig
da und sagen ja wir sind die neue
bürgerliche Partei ich will ihnen sagen
wenn sie konservativ und bürgerlich sein
wollen dann gehört dazu Anstand und auch
Stil und beides lassen Sie hier komplett
vermissen
jetzt kann man an Angela Merkel
natürlich kritisieren und werden uns ja
vorgemacht hat sind die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der CDU und der CSU in den
letzten Tagen also das ist
selbstverständlich erlaubt auch
angesichts einer solchen Verleihung und
sie brauchen ja schon fast die AFD damit
sie heute geschlossen Angela Merkel
bejubeln können wie sie das heute
gemacht haben im Parlament also es ist
kaum zu verdecken dass sie nach dem Erbe
Angela Merkel auf der Suche nach einem
konservativen Profil sind gut bisschen
gegen Ausländer bisschen für Atom ich
wünsche Ihnen da weiter gute Verrichtung
auf der Sinn auf der Sinnsuche meine
Kollegen von der CDU aber Kritik ist
erlaubt und ich will die Debatte auch
dazu nutzen zu sagen dass wir in diesem
Land manchmal auch
unbarmherzige Diskussionen schon haben
wenn es darum geht nach wem ist eine
Straße benannt
auf für wen ist ein Denkmal auf einem
unserer Plätze errichtet wenn wir das
machen wollen dass es nur Menschen sind
die nie ein Fehler gemacht haben oder
deren Lebensbilanz ohne jeden Zweifel
ist dann wäre es auf unseren Plätzen
leer und dann könnten wir unsere Straßen
auch nur nach irgendwelchen
trockenpflanzen benennen deswegen
sollten wir hier achten darauf dass wir
natürlich kritisieren können aber auch
barmherzig umgehen Ohnmacht eine
Referenz an Angela Merkel zu machen man
darf auch nach Bayreuth gehen und einen
Wagner genießen ohne gleichzeitig jeden
Unsinn in dieser Mann verzapft hat gut
finden zu müssen
und abschließend das ist auch warm man
muss da nicht hingehen jedem selbst
überlassen wir sind ein freies Land
abschließend jede Verleihung eines
Ordens in diesem Land ist nicht nur eine
Auszeichnung für die Person die ihn
verliehen bekommt sondern sie ist auch
eine Erinnerung daran dass niemand
irgendetwas leisten kann ohne dass sehr
viele Menschen im Stillen im Hintergrund
im familiären Umfeld mithelfen teilweise
morgens aufstehen ohne ganz genau zu
wissen was heute wieder ihr Beitrag zum
großen Ganzen sein kann und so ist es
selbstverständlich bei einer
Bundeskanzlerin auch und wenn sie für 16
Jahre hier einen groß das Großkreuz des
Verdienstordens bekommt dann ist es auch
eine Auszeichnung an die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger dieses Landes dass wir zusammen
geschafft haben und versucht haben unser
Land voranzubringen und allen dafür
herzlichen Dank
abschließend noch zwei gute Nachrichten
einmal auch die AFD hat jetzt so hohe
Maßstäbe an dieses Verdienstkreuz hier
formuliert das klar ist von ihnen wird
Ihnen nie jemand diesen Orden bekommen
und zweitens da noch mal an die Kollegin
Joris auch die unnötigste aktuelle
Stunde nimmt ein wahlanal ein Ende und
zwar jetzt ich wünsche Ihnen weiter
erfolgreichen Tag ja und damit hat Lars
castellucci für die SPD hier
diese aktuelle Stunde beendet als der
Orden am Montagabend in Bellevue an
Angela Merkel verliehen wurde hat sie
auch eine kurze Ansprache gehalten und
hat unter anderem gesagt Zitat es wird
oft gesprochen was für eine
Schlangengrube Politik ist ich darf
sagen ich hätte es nicht überlebt wenn
es nicht auch die andere Seite der
Politik gibt deshalb konnte es mir immer
Freude machen Zitat Ende Angela Merkel
am Montag bei der Verleihung dieses
Ordens